welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University visit w WC mu edu slash
multimedia
you
computer juice and a thorough account
I appreciate your joining me me and me
and Earl today for what I would like to
be a discussion so i will give you a few
false if you will about political
processes that are currently going on in
the united states called the united
states presidential primaries and you
and I have probably both know an equal
amount about because we all get our news
from CNN I have I have although I am now
a political junkie if you will because
of the ongoing presidential race that as
opposed to six weeks in Australia last
for a millennium in the United States
with its it's something that I think is
interesting and important calls for
instance we have just witnessed as a
November an electoral process in
Australia and it was for me a great
thing to witness another democracy in
its electoral process it is very
different than the electoral process
that we are now witnessing in the United
States it is one in which there is
pre-selection if you will by the
australian party say is there's a cause
of elected australian
the Liberal Party in the National Party
the Labour Party and they select their
leader who then leads them into the
electoral for a without a whole lot of
public debate we used to do that in the
United States and we had a meany hall in
new york historically where the bosses
determine who was going to be the
candidate in more modern times there
would be those that would say mayor
daley in chicago eh crump in Memphis
Tennessee my hometown these were
individuals that by virtue of their
political prowess and their influence
with other elected officials basically
determined who would run and by virtue
of their determination of who would run
hit determine who would be elected the
American reformers then instituted a
different process a caucus process if
you will in which anybody that was a
party member to come to and so if you
are interested in running for office as
the nominee of a particular party and it
moved you to get organized and get your
people who would vote for you and
actually show up and spend the day at a
particular caucus today or in other
states they anybody who jah and say i'm
a member of the
cratic party the republican party with
old losses fighting the Libertarian
Party of whatever Party and Allen
participating your calls in most states
and the states determined it so it was
different in say a state the other thing
that occurred in the united states for
the Reformers is that the concept that
we want in the united states have the
people more involved in the selection of
the candidates rather than the party
bosses we're distrustful of the
potential corruption of the party bosses
the control of the party bosses that
don't respond as quickly as they might
otherwise to the will the people and so
we'll have a primary process in which
one Republican candidate will compete
against another Republican candidate or
faculty candidates will compete against
each other or ten candidates democratic
will compete against each other and the
coders will go out and go to polls just
lightly with an election day and
determine who will be the candidate for
that particular part so that's a very
just different system than a
pre-selection system done I have the
elected officials of the part even our
caucuses are different and then in the
United States we went to a dish
reforms that were involved with is it a
winner take all or is it a proportionate
division of Delegates if we have a
caucus or primary another second aspect
that was very different between the
United States of America and our process
there and watching the electoral process
in Australia was that Australia has
mandatory voting everybody's gotta come
out vote or you get fine so you say well
it's what i need to do today more
important than the 50 or 100 dollar fine
but i'm gonna get if I don't show up I
don't have to vote I can show up check
my name off tape about you know throw it
in the trash or put it in those without
marking it it's a donkey balloted votes
for nobody but I at least have to go
then the thought is that if you have to
go to the polling place you're more
likely to vote they're not and you know
not many people spend the time to go to
the polls and then coated on staff and
the thought is in that type of mandatory
voting process that if you actually know
before me I got to vote you'll be
incentivized and motivated to find out
something about candidates and something
about the issues okay and therefore you
will have a more informed electorate who
comes in and cast their ballots on the
true issues that are facing the electric
of that particular that I discussed that
with other Australian
scientists and academics and they say
there is a body of fault that such as
the case Australian voters are more
informed but there is a contrary theory
out there that some academics and
political scientists express and that is
that most Australian elections are
determined by those in the middle and
that that about fifteen percent of the
actual voters that show up and vote in
Australia say when they walk into the
polling place they have no idea who
they're gonna vote and they go and they
go according to these political science
on what the candidate was wearing the
last time they saw whether they like the
cut of the dress that the candidate was
wearing whether they like the cut of the
suit the candidate was wearing whether
they liked the family whether they liked
where they were living how they related
to the sound of their voice on the
television things that had nothing to do
with the issue issues of the day
whatsoever and at those fifty percent of
the ones to decide the election and
there
or mandatory voting has a negative side
to it I have no interest in that debate
other than to be fascinated that there
is a debate about within Australia from
time to time we and Americans rugged
individualists if somebody were to
propose a law in the united states that
said you have to poke or you will be
fined a hundred dollars people would be
up in arms by golly I have a right not
to them and I don't want to vote the
government should be telling me to vote
if I want to be a disinterested citizen
I don't care what happens then I've got
the right to be disinterested and not
care what happens and you can't tell me
to be interested in no because i'm not
i'm not sure that's a positive attitude
that i want to promulgate from the
citizens of any democracy but there are
Americans who are and it's reflected in
our history are distrustful of
government telling them you've got to do
something they distrust government and
that's why
bill rights in the United States we
don't have one that says you don't have
to vote but we have bills of rights in
the United States because people are
fearful of the charity of the majority
and therefore Congress shall pass no law
abridging the freedom of religion
because we all want the majority of
people who might vote to tell me what is
the state religion to be able to do that
and so they're all sorts of things in
the American character that are it not
hostile not supportive of a mandatory by
the hook the other thing in the United
States is we have basically a
winner-take-all electoral system and
that is you get the most votes and you
win and if there are 15 candidates that
are running for the office and you get
the most votes some states say that you
must have 50.00 000 1% you got have a
majority so if they're 15 candidates and
you got 49 point
nine percent of the vote you would have
to go to ralphs against the person that
was in second place okay and a runoff
requires another election day and
showing up to actually cast your ballot
and get your boat out so in a lot of
local elections in the United States
certainly in my state of Georgia you
would have someone who led by
forty-eight percent of the boat was
running against somebody they got
twenty-three percent of the vote and
there were you know 250,000 people that
help you at all the wrong there were 25
thousand people that voted because they
didn't want to go to the boats of that
one race and some so we had twenty three
percent of the original battles was
elected dog catcher or school board or
whatever a different sort of system from
that in Australia which has what
preferential voting so that if you go to
the puddles and there are five
candidates running of different parties
and you then pick one two three four
five as to your preference and if you
are in favor of one candidate and you
know that it's really a contest between
Canada and headed a B and you put your
candidate candidate a is number one on
your ballot and where you put candidate
bit who's the greatest threat you
metadata you put their number 5 i'm
going to real number five you play games
you play a game here if you will with
your preference will open and it was
fascinating to me as an American to
watch election returns come in in
Australia and it would say here's the
wrong boat and it was like a rule that
machine here's the preferential look and
the person that was ahead in the rowboat
all of a sudden was behind in the
preferential oh and that's unusual to
the folks coming from the United States
to see that the other thing that I found
fascinating about the Australian process
was proportionate representation in the
Senate and that is if you got a stick
your party got a certain level a vote
then low ball you got your heart cut AC
and sent from that particular Senate
area whereas in the United States again
it's winner-take-all either win it or
young and if you've got seventeen
percent of the vote for eighteen percent
of the vote no one in the United States
to think that you had a right or your
party had a right to have a
representative in the Senate on the
basis of twenty percent of it's a
different sort of approach to the
democratic process and point is so
beautiful about it to an American these
days is that it convinces one in a very
personal way that your political theory
intellectual acceptance of democracy as
being capable of numerous forms is in
fact correct is in fact valid the system
in Australian works because it's not
rating system that is embraced by people
of the Commonwealth of Australia it
would not necessarily be embraced by the
people of the United States of America
nor would the visitors to process is in
the United States of America being
embraced by the people of the
Commonwealth of all straight and put
that should tell us all is it there is
no cookie cutter format for
representative accountable responsive go
is what the people themselves design is
the appropriate way to share power in a
compromise of different fashions and one
of the things that I kind of met life
reaffirming if you will in terms of
political philosophy is that we in the
world today are faced with increasing
numbers of democracies they don't look
like each other that don't have the same
structure and that all have a legitimacy
provided the people who are governed our
satisfied and in fact are embracing of
the structure under which the decisions
of a now in the United States I
mentioned today it's lunch when I was
talking with the people at Pancham about
the questions that I'm asked when I am
talking about the economic relationship
between the United States of America
Australia that I'm always asked the
question in the whatever context it is
of what
is going on with your primary process
and who's now in the Democratic
nomination for president you know I
absolutely no idea and as I said coming
in I'm is fascinated by it as you are
but think for one second about the
activities that are that are there going
on and the people in the united states
that were involved in them and then look
at the people in Australia that were
involved in the electoral process and I
think it's something that Australians
and people in the United States and can
take great joy in and take great
confidence in no matter who wins the
election that our countries are going to
be responsible and accountable to the
people that are governed look at the
people in Australia in in terms of their
ability and their capacity and
willingness to serve the people of the
Commonwealth of Australia and you know
you go down John Howard and Peter
Costello and you know Alexander Downer
on the mountain turnbull on the
liberal-national coalition side whether
you agree with them or not doesn't
matter they're all people of great
integrity and credibility and then look
at the people on the labor side you know
Kevin Rudd Joel Fitzgibbon Steve Smith
Kim easily the former leader of the
Opposition people who had served their
country with distinction and well over
many many years and then you look at the
candidates in the United States of
America on the Republican side Rudy
Giuliani the mayor of New York John
Hanke Mitt Romney who is you know a
tremendous success and public servant
success in business and a public servant
Gymkhana Mike Huckabee the governor of
Arkansas who distinguished himself
during his time down there and on the
Democratic side you have John Edwards
Hillary Rodham Clinton buyer bah Joe
Biden you have people who have done
wonderful things for their country and
committed themselves in many many ways
so it's a situation where both
Australians and Americans can take you
know great pride in what has what the
electoral process has produced for the
for the voters choices one of the things
that that you know I wanted to do was to
and the current state of affairs McCain
and is supposedly 1022 delegates and he
eats 1191 and there are any number of
primaries next Tuesday Wednesday in
Australia which could give him the
nomination if he wins in terms of
Delegates that are coming on in the
immediate future next Tuesday March a
march 10th so he's he's got within the
next several weeks an opportunity before
the end of March to tie up that
combination hola has 1134 pledged
delegates against 996 for Hillary Rodham
Clinton but he also has 168
super-delegates where she has 239 so it
is neck and neck if you will between
Hillary Rodham Clinton and Barack Obama
i had the pleasure of studying in
England with
Bill Clinton and then at law school with
both bill and hillary clinton hillary
rodham at that time and there I'm a
Republican you know I'm been appointed
up was it cool with President Bush as
well acted in his campaign so obviously
I see things through a Republican prism
if you will but I've had to tell you
that all that as I just hit all of those
candidates on each side of the aisle
will serve the United States well and
our Wellington thoughtful people who
have a particular political philosophy
that they believe would be in the best
interest of the American people and so
on as in America must rejoice it and
celebrate that sort of a choice that
that faces the American people obviously
as a Republican and as I say I see
things through a particular prism and I
will certainly exercise my right to vote
by absentee from the state of Georgia
and I have encouraged consistently every
member of the United States mission to
vote absentee regardless of who they're
going to local because that's the way
that we ultimately get a decision that
all of us can embrace and and support my
last point is I continue to receive
questions about the relationship
the United States and Australia and how
change in government has affected and I
must tell you that the United States and
Australia have a remarkably close
relationship on multiple levels is broad
it is deep and it is diverse in terms of
the number of relationships that we have
military intelligence economic cultural
of this weekend at the arts festival of
an analytic we will have Americans
performing in a language that
Australians will relate to and
understand because of the cultural
affinity between our countries and that
is a great and wonderful thing and Prime
Minister Rudd has basically said the
relationship between Australia in the
United States transcends which
administration is in out which
government is in power in all trade any
transcends which government or
administration is in power in Washington
and that is a matter on which I think
all Australians and all Americans and
also for choice